フストレートだったら
いきなりショック来ちゃうんで
前もって言わなかったらもう俺ダメですよと
ですからもう情動というのは
まあ僕らはそういうふうに訓練を受けてきたからね
できるんであって できなくて
もう私たちにも情動はあるんです
人の前に喋るんだけど
例えば偉いお坊さんたちの前に喋らせちゃったらなかなか言葉出ないというか
どこかで言葉失敗してたらどうするんですかとか
かなり緊張するというかね
それどんなお坊さんにもあるみたいんです
僕はあるかどうか分かりませんだけど
とにかく喋れない お坊さんたちの前で逃げるんです
で  それったら別に緊張しないかもしれませんけど
でも大胆なこと言っちゃうでしょ
それでも それはやっぱりもうお坊さんとしてはね
もういろいろ決まりありますからね
決まり破っちゃったら
もうそれすごいまずいんだからね
その点ではもう混乱するというか
情動が生まれるというかね
であの情動っていうのは
ですから基本的なもので
心が隠れたがる 隠れたがる心が隠れ場所が消えちゃったら外に出ちゃうんですね
外へ出た瞬間でもう混乱になっちゃう
ですから 混乱状態 情動っていうのは
この古いテキストでは
この肺に何か石なんか投げたような状態で
肺がさっと出て行って落ち着きがない状態だと説明しているんです
野生の動物でも連れてきて
どこかへいきなりオープンな場所に出しちゃったら
すごい混乱状態になるんです
人間も同じと なんで子供たちが幼稚園入れちゃったらすごく泣くんですか？という
情動なんですね 隠れて親のもう母親のスカートの中に隠れて安心してしたのに
いきなり社会に出しちゃったらもう適応できなくなっちゃっている
そこは誰にでもありますよ
大人になって会社に入って
初めの 1週間の 1週間もかなり情動なんですよ
汗が出るわ 指が震えるわ
膝が震えるわ 心臓がドキドキするわ
いろいろあるんです だから超越した知恵を振りちぎるや
これは問題なんです 心は隠れたがる
強引にでも外に出ちゃったら
もう混乱する どうしようもないんです
次に出てくるのはクックッチという言葉なんですね
クックッチっていうのは
もう言葉通りに後悔なんですね
後悔すること 後悔する場合は
自分がだいたい何か過去でやった失敗
ミス 間違ったことを思い出したりする
思い出 やっぱり失敗したったら
ものすごくストレス溜まっちゃうんですね
何か失敗したらあ いけないと
あ 嫌だと ストレスというもの溜まっちゃうんですね
それを思い出すと もっと気持ち悪くなっちゃうんです
また思い出しちゃうとまた気持ち悪くなっちゃうんです
だから後悔はとんでもないハンディなんです
そこでなんで超越知恵にそれ関わりありますかというと
後悔する連中はいつでも過去に惹かれてるんですね
過去で起きた出来事に惹かれてあって
事実の心理の世界に心が向けないんです
瞑想する時でも さっとそれを思い浮かんだりするんですね
だからもう開き直った方がいいんです
瞑想する場合は 今までどんな悪いことをしてきたっても
そんなものはどうでもいいんだと
開き直れと 明るい心で始まるしか方法ないです
仏教では後悔は罪だと思っているんです
後悔する人は罪を犯しているんです
あの何か間違いした場合も間違いだから
それはいけないんだけど
まあ上手にできないんだから間違うんだからね
まあしょうがないといえばしょうがないんでしょう
たとえ人のものを盗んだっても
その時は自分がものを欲しくて
目が見えなくなっちゃって
もう感情にやられちゃって
心理わからなくて 理性失っちゃって盗んでしまっちゃったと
だからまあ感情にやらせられた
やらされたぐらいのことで
まあしょうがないことでしょうがないんですよね
それで後悔するたびに
あの罪を新しく新しく思い出す
思い出どんどん罪の重さが大きくなっちゃうんです
ですから 後悔だけは絶対してはいけないんです
この悔い改めると言うんですか
やらない方がいいんです
天国に行きたければ  [笑い]まあ悔やんで改めるんじゃなくて
まあただ改めるっていうぐらいだけだったらね
本当に人間っていうのはどれほど無知かというと
真剣に悔い改める原理を信じる人々が自分の過去の出来事を思い出して泣いたりとして
どうぞ私の罪を許してくださいと
あのバカが バカどもが本当にやった間違いはさらに思い出して泣いたりして
もっと強烈なせちゃうんですね
そこで許してくださいとすごい誤解するんですね
その上邪見も入っちゃいますからね
間違いはどんな人間もするんでしょうに
それを思い出しちゃうとその倍になっちゃうし
その上邪見にすべちゃいますからね
あ 治りましたと ですから言葉が良くないんだけども
開き直った方がいいんです
開き直るという言葉はね
あまりいいニュアンスが持ってないんだけどね
でも分かりやすいんですね
例えば人にあんたこの間こんなことをしたんではないかとかね
あんた去年こういうことしたんではないかとか言ったと
だからそれ去年でしょ？だから何ですかと
私に仕事をくれと あんた去年も失敗して
それは去年でしょうに
だから今年も失敗するということはないでしょうにと
そういう法則ないんだから仕事をくれと
あんたよくも開き直ってるんだと
その方がもう一応明るくていいと思いますよ
本当に去年は仕事を大変失敗して申し訳ございませんと
言ったら今年仕事ちょうだいと言えないでしょうに
だから人にこれはダメです
失敗 失敗か なるほど 失敗だ
これは じゃあ直そうと
そんなふうな生き方なんです
正しい生き方っていうのは
会社でもね 自分やっている仕事はなんかこれはどうだと上司に言われたら
みんなこの若い女性たちなんかはね
すごい精神的に傷つかかっちゃうんですね
偉そうなこと これダメですよと言われたら
ああそう ダメか なるほど
ああ やっぱりそうですねとか
じゃあ直しますと 自分で直せばいいんだ
自分でわからなかったら
やっぱり私にできないんだから教えてちょうだいと
どのふうにこれをやりますかと
上司の義務だから教えてあげるのは
何のことなく楽に生きていられますよ
この世の中で ほんのちょっとしたことで
それみんなこのむちゃくちゃこの混乱だらけでね
あの猫にあの糸 糸で遊びしたら猫は糸をあっちこっちあったり
もう解けないですよ それからはそんな状態なんです
我々の心っていうのは
猫が糸巻きで遊ぶことと同じなんですね
糸はちゃんと巻いておけば何のこともないんです
物になりましてね じゃあ後悔っていうのは後悔であって
過去のことを思い出しちゃうと心が暗くなってエネルギーが消えちゃう
それで超自然的な知識が生まれなくなっちゃうんです
で 最後です 最後は疑ですね
道義ちゃん 疑 疑いの疑
その疑いの疑がありまして
疑は良くないんだと そこで気をつけてほしいのは
この私もよくこの疑いなさいとか何とか言うんですね
その疑いっていうのは知識的で飲み込むなと
うのみするなと 物事を
正しいか否か確かめること
物事を理解するために
ものすごい力強く元気で正しいか否か
自分で確かめて理解する
人間というのはすごい弱いもんで
この偉大なる先生に教えてもらいたい
それもまたわかりやすい美しい言葉です
それはうのみする そんなものは人間がやるものじゃないんです
徹底的に自分で確かめてみる
それは僕は一般的な言葉で疑って疑ってみなさいと言うんであって
それは仏教でいう悪いこととして言っている疑ではないんです
あれは疑ではなくて元気なんですね
真理するために あまりにも元気があって
精神的な力があって 非ということはうのみしない
それだけのことで こちらで疑っていうのは
心の弱みなんですね これでいいかなとか本当かなとか
そんな状態なんですね
もしかすると間違ったらどうかなとか
全然どっちにもならない
そんな状態だったら しっかりしてないでしょ
しっかりしていない状態
例えば瞑想したら悟れると言ったら
そうかな どうかなとかね
そうかなどうかなではなくて
本当に悟る じゃあやってみる
それが私が正しいと言っている疑いなんですね
あんたが言っても私は信じませんと
そんなにも悟るんだって
じゃあ瞑想してみると
それも疑って当たることですけど
その人は元気でやってみるんですね
で よくあるでしょ 食べたこともないのを食べて
あれはやっぱり自分が食べないんだろうと
腹が立つんで その場合は
食べてみておいしくないというならばわかりますけど
食べたことがない食べ物あれ食べたくないと
なんです 私はおいしくないと
偉そうなことを言うんですね
ああいう性格だったら
もう瞑想の世界じゃないんです
やっぱり怖いもの知らないという感じで
疑いで試してみた方がいいんです
ですから 疑というのはこの
そういう試そうともしないで
もう否定する 疑う 力がない
弱い その疑なんです 例えば今
これからアビダンマでこの超自然的な心の方が入ってますけど
もうそれはもうわからないのは当たり前ですけど
やっぱり科学的じゃないとかね
なんとかとか いい加減な言葉言って信じませんと
信じませんじゃなくて
これこうこうやり方できる心だと言ってるんだから
科学的な人だったら試してみればどうですかね
あるかないかと 試して試してダメやというならば
そこはもういくらか理解できますけどね
私は 1 年間瞑想してみたんだけど
全然そういう智慧がなかったというならば
その人は正しいことを言っているんです
ですから この疑い いわゆるしっかりしない
ただ何でも疑う それだけ
信じませんとただ言うだけの
このいわゆる腰抜け状態ですか
そんな風な状態のもう心の状態なんですね
それをまた基本的に大体あるんです
新しいものにチャレンジしたくない心があるでしょ
私はこの新しい仏教を語っているんだけど
かなり反論やら反感とかいっぱいあるんですね
別にもし戦ってるわけでもないし
攻撃してるわけでもないし
もうチャレンジしてみればいいのに
私は他の宗教を信じているんだから
まあ教会と活動はなんとか控えていただきますとか
なんとかとかね なんか腰抜けだなと思っちゃう
別に信仰してくださいと頼んでもないのに
そういう言葉を聞くだけでももう嫌になっちゃう
まあもう人間になってないんで
まだまだ そうじゃなくて
私はもう生まれた時からキリスト教ですよと
でもあなた方の教えを勉強してみると
三年勉強してたのに でも私はキリスト教というなら
僕はすごくしっかりしてる人だなと思っちゃいますよ
頑固で自分の立場でいるんだから
その分かわいいんですよ
そうじゃなくて やっぱり他宗教は私は怖いですよとかね
それだったら僕にもキリスト教の勉強できなくなるんだから
僕は堂々と勉強したんだから
でお寺にいたんだけど
僕の勉強してた時 僕の机の上にキリスト教のテキストやら資料やらもういっぱい散々あったのに
誰お坊さんたちも お前何やってるんでしょう
一言も言われたことがないんです
聖書は必死になって最後から最初から最後まで読みましたから
小さい時に で 別に覚えようと思わなかったんだから
このいろいろ名前とか言葉とかね
まあアベルとかあだこで
そんなものは飛んじゃうんですね
それは全部飛んで飛んで飛んで
内容だけ読んでいっちゃうんですね
まあそれでそれで専門家の神父さんから
あんたもうとんでもないことやってるんだから
それは絶対読んでいけないんだと
僕はなんで？と そんなこともう一人勝手に読んで理解できるものじゃないんだと
頭がおかしくなるかもしれない
そんなに怖いの？全然
僕はもうガキでしたけどね
教えてくれる人々もみんなもうプロ中のプロで
向こうはもう読むな読むなと言われているのに
僕はもう読んだんです
そこで僕はチャレンジしたのがカトリック教会なんですね
聖書を出してくれと 読んだのはプロテスタントの聖書で
カトリック教はそれを文句読むんですね
それでじゃあカトリックを勉強しますと言ったら
自分たちが聖書からあっちから一つこっちから一つ引用して教えてくれるんですね
これ 僕には気が済まない
なんで我々はあなたの解説を聞かなくちゃいけないんだと
聖書を出してくれと言ったら返事来るんですね
それは普通には人は読んではいけないものだと
で 嫌になっちゃったんです
嫌になってカトリック教を勉強するのはやめちゃったんです
で 面白いとこいっぱいカトリックあるよ
お祭りあるわね いろいろ
ね あの すごくなんか舞台演劇みたいな
メッサとかね なんかドラマですね
面白いことは面白いんだけど
神父さんたちも色々なすげえきれいな色々服を着て
なんかこうやって ね 子供たちがいろんななんかね
服装着たり 多分ろうそくを持ったりとか
で 面白いんだけど 勉強したかったんだけど
もうバカの連中だからやめちゃったんで
聖書を読むなって言うんだから
まあそれはそれで別にこの
そういうこの元気というかね
それが人間に必要なんですね
この元気で物事にチャレンジすると
そうすると知恵が得られるんです
あれ怖いこれ怖いと隠れる心があったら何もできないんですね
ですから 例えば山を登りたいんだと
でも上は酸素が足らないでしょうとかね
やっぱり寒いでしょうとかね
滑ったらどうするんですかとかね
登山したらどうする？登さんとですか？そしたらどうです
え？遭難したらどうするんですか？とかね
それだったら登りくはないんだからね
だからそういう状態 心にいつでもあるんですね
ですから やっぱり超越したこの心のレベルを作りたければ
この技能レベルも技能障害も乗り越えなくちゃいけない
その 5つも人間には基本的に障害だからね
基本的にあるんです それは煩悩とかあだことと言えるところじゃないんです
まあ煩悩と言えば煩悩なんですけど
あまり煩悩扱いもしないんです
ちょっとした便利なんですね
それで心がもう覆われているんです
ですから 仏教で二悪と言うんですね
五 二悪 これ二っていうのは何で出てきたか分かりませんだけど
これあ悪の蓋 害ですか
蓋という意味なんですね
もうこれパーリの世界では二悪の涅槃に蓋をかけられているんだから
二悪というふうな解釈ありますけど
あれはまあただ仏教的な解釈で
そんなに学問的な立場がないんです
ただの悪っていうのはもう蓋をかけてるっていう意味で
二っていうのはものすごくこの強くという
この これ英語でインという
英語でもこれアイエンつけるプレフィックスがあるんですね
この動詞にインつけちゃったら力強くなっちゃうんですね
例えば何でしたっけ？なかなか思い出せる言葉ありますか
え？ああそう エンカレッジの場合
それもいいエンですけどね
それもないですけど であるんだけど
なかなか思い出せないな
もう英語忘れちゃったんだ
ボケたんだ まあ今思い出せると include それから
immerse とかね
IM なんですけどね  merge ということは emerge という言葉が作れるし
IM EN IM とかそういう
まあそれ似てるプレフィックスだと思いますけど
ニっていうのは 似てる意味なんですね
とにかく ですからこのしっかりと蓋をかけてるっていう意味なんですね
ニ悪 ですから この 5つの障害で心にはしっかりと蓋をかけているんです
だから次元の中にいるしか方法ないんです
いるのはいいんだけど
超越した知識がないと偉そうなこと言ってますね
仏教だったらね ありっこないんだと
だから一度も水から出てきた出たことがない水の中に生活している魚なんかは
まあ陸上の生活を否定する
そんなことはありえないんだと
気持ちはわかるんです
なぜならば魚は死んじゃうんですね
陸上に上がっちゃったら
ですから 魚にとっては陸上に上がった方が一番いいやと言ったっても
それはもう理解できない
我々の心にとっても この五欲を捨てましょうと
現に必死に耐えることをやめましょうと言われたら
これちょっと冗談の話じゃないんです
魚に水から出てこいということと同じなんですね
こちら楽しいよと言ったら楽しいところじゃないんです
それは死んじゃうんです
ですから 瞑想して禅定を作ると思っても
私たちは死ぬぐらいの恐怖感に出会うんです
五蓋をなくすということで
別にどうったこと 暗闇が怖いということと同じなんですよ
どうったことないんです
別に暗い時 なんで怖いんですかね
何の意味もない ただそれだけでも
ですから五蓋を捨てちゃえば
もうその瞬間で清浄が生まれるんです
で 五蓋捨てたら清浄の心生まれるしか他の方法ないんです
心には 自然的に なぜならば
もう眼耳鼻舌身に頼らないでしょ
それから妄想にも頼ってないでしょ
妄想の働きも五つ 眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報の
情報の回転だから それもカーマ・チャンダなんですね
それやめちゃったら心が終わる
止まらないんだから 心は回転する
で もう自然に心は超次元的なレベルで回転するしか方法ないんです
だから何のことなく超次元に心は回転し始めちゃうんです
すごい簡単に生まれるんです
清浄な心が その点では
問題は五蓋を抑えることなんです
五蓋 五蓋ってのは蓋という字書くんですね
今説明した五蓋を抑えることだけなんですね
なんで今日はこの まあちょっと授業を飛び出してこれ説明したんですかというと
これはヴィパッサナー瞑想についても同じことなんです
瞑想はやっぱり順番に着々と進んでほしいければ
我々は座るたびに 瞑想するたびに
歩く瞑想するたびに この邪魔物に出会うんです
五つの邪魔物に出会うんです
だから出会ったすぐそれはしっかりと確認してほしいんです
自分の瞑想の道の道を足を引っ張ってるんですね
引っ張られてるんですね
で あ 今日はこれで邪魔されているんだ
今日は昏沈睡眠で邪魔されているんだと
今日は後悔で邪魔されているんだと
そういう風にこの瞑想はなぜ進むし進まないかと
だからヴィパッサナーの場合はサティ入れることだけだから
丁寧に確認していく それだけで十分です
それうまくいかないんですね
うまくいかないと あ 今日は何に惹かれてるかなと
ちょっと見ておく必要があるんです
で 見ただけでいくらか抑えるんですね
今日は欲で 一応カーマ・チャンダ
例えばいろんなことを思い出したりする
昨日やったこと 今日やったこと
これからやることとかね
瞑想で妄想が出てくる
それは正真正銘のカーマ・チャンダなんですね
五欲に惹かれていると
あ これはカーマ・チャンダだと
あるいは日本語で言えば欲
欲望だと 今日は欲望にやられてるんだとね
欲望に邪魔されて妄想が
欲望の妄想やと それを確認する
それだけ それで結構 何回
何回確認すると落ちつくんです
そこで嫌になってくるかもしれません
早く終わらないかとかね
それは怒りであって で怒りが出てくると
また落ち着きが消えちゃう
今怒りが怒りの障害があるんだと
だから気持ちよく瞑想できないんだ
なぜ気持ちよく瞑想できない
怒りの障害なんだ これは怒りの障害と
それを勉強する そういうふうにこの五蓋を確認するということは必要なんです
それ確認していくと 結構早く瞑想は進んでしまいます
それはサマーディ瞑想にしたっても
ヴィパッサナー瞑想にしたっても
それは必要なんです この
この怒りの時にドッカとかいろんな期間はありますけど
ヴィアーパーダという五蓋の時の怒りに近いものは
うーん まあ独立して言葉を使うといろいろニュアンスの差があるんです
で ニュアンスの差使うのは
この場合は今の私の定義で使った方がいいと思います
ヴィアーパーダは辞書的な意味で言えば瞋恚であって
すごい強烈な怒りなんです
それは道徳的な分析すると
そういうふうに分析するんです
ドーサといえば基本的な怒りなんですね
それは強烈じゃないんです
いわゆる気持ち悪い いわゆる基本的な怒りで
ヴィアーパーダでというと強烈な怒りでコントロールできないほど怒りが強烈なんですね
でも五蓋の場合はまた違うんですね
だから瞑想してるんだから
強烈な怒りなんかは出る
出ることはないんだからね
ただ怒りが生まれるだけだと
たまにあるんですよ 強烈に怒りが生まれる場合も
瞑想している人々の間では
たまにはあるんです それはもう心のことやってますから
もう感情はそっと爆発したりとかね
それは仏教ではなかなかないんだけど
他の瞑想ではね まあそれほど心理学的にそんなにうるさいほど分析してないでしょ？ただ抑えなさいとかね
このしきたり守れとかね
そういう風に言ってるんだから
もうちょっと危険なところもあるんです
例えば強引に断食させちゃう
強引に彩色すぎるしちゃうとかね
いろいろ儀式 儀式 いろんなしきたりばっかりやらせて瞑想させちゃうとかね
で 上手くいる人はうまくいきますけど
そこでストレス溜まっちゃって爆発する可能性もありますね
仏教の世界ではそんなに経験もあまり記録もないんで
そういうふうに精神的にいかれたということはね
そこはもうものすごい厳密に分析しているんだから
もう一人勝手に瞑想したっても
もう問題にはならないんですよ
すごいこの徹底的にもう勉強して分析していますから
ですから問題ないんだけど
一応このヴィアーパーダと
ヴィアーパーダというのは瞋恚で
文字の意味はね 言葉の意味は瞋恚で強烈な怒り
で 強烈な怒りっていうのは普段はないでしょうね
瞑想する人々には 人を殺してやりたいぐらいに怒りあって瞑想する人はいませんだからね
ですから 私が思うのは
そのヴィアーパーダの辞書の意味はそこで使わないと
そうじゃなくて 生命に基本的にある便利ですからね
ですからヴィアーパーダ・ニーヴァーナという形容詞使うんです
これはいつでもこのニーヴァーナと形容詞使うんです
カーマ・チャンダ・ニーヴァーナ
ヴィアーパーダ・ニーヴァーナ
ウッダッチクッティーナニッダ・ニーヴァーナ
そういうことです ニーヴァーナという言葉使えば今日の解釈
ニーヴァーナ捨てちゃえば強烈な怒りという意味なんです
そこでこの障害が機能しなくなった
あるいは障害には打ち勝ったと
ということは 心っていうのはものすごい巨大なエネルギーを持ってることなんですね
いわゆる原理に執着に頼らなくなっても大丈夫だ
平気だという ものすごい自信満々な状態
自分の死の恐怖感に乗り勝ったことだから
ものを見えなきゃ人は死ぬほど怖いし
音が聞こえなくなったら死ぬほど怖いし
これカワマッチャンに割に打ち勝ったということは
ものすごい自信満々な状態でものすごい力強い状態なんです
それで怒りがないということは
ものすごい明るいというか
それから 3番目 ティーナミントですね
もう隠れることは全くない
そうそう で 眠気も何もないと
すごい活発的で そこでウッダッチャッとはもうないと
ウッダッチャッというのはもう混乱状態は全くない
落ち着いている 隠れようともしない
心は表に出すと それまた表に出ても混乱もなしと
最後にこのギ ブチ切っちゃうもなし
もうしっかりしてすごいチャレンジ精神で
という この精神的に言えば究極的な素晴らしい状態になっちゃうと
すぐ次の瞬間に禅定状態の心が生まれる
そこを理解すると 世の中に禅定があるんだ
悟ったんだとか言ってる人々は
言ってるのは正しいかなんかと理解できます
だから仏教は直接は言わない
あんた方は教えてるんだとかね
ただ科学的に禅定の状態は分析する
分析したら なぜならばどんな人にも瞑想すれば禅定は作られますよ
それは宗教と関係ないんです
宗教全くない若者 子供でも
それなりの超越する方法をやれば禅定が生まれる可能性はあるんです
それはある一つの宗教のものとかね
それは仏教でそういうふうに言いたくないし
で 問題は この例えば子供がなんとか訓練したところで
なんとか特別な特別な経験を得ているんだと
それは禅定がないかと科学的に判断したい
心理学的に そこでこちらはシステムがあるんです
これはもうきちんとしたシステムで
そういうふうな精神的にすごいしっかりしていて
抜群に力が 精神的な力が揃っていて
また徹底的に落ち着いている人だったら
まあ禅定でしょうと というようなんです
禅定は体験しているんだけど
いまだにこの まあ食べ
あれ食べたい これ食べたいとかね
眠たいとかね ああだこうだと人に怒るは威張るはもうなんか自分の立場を作ろうとああだこうだとかね
そういう状態だったら
もう何のこともない ただのもう普通の人よりまあいいかというかね
禅定できると同時にそれぐらい人もできてるんです
性格も 立派な人になっちゃうんです
で 禅定の問題は その働きが抑えることだけなんですね
働きが機能しない それ元気になったと
元気になったら禅定が生まれる
でもこの元気な状態ずっとあるんですかと言えば
そこはないんです またどこかで力が消えちゃったら
またもう超越意識がなくなっちゃって
やっぱり生きるためにまた現に物質に頼るようになっちゃうということもあるんですね
ですから 絶対的ではないんですね
絶対的になるためにはヴィパッサナーでこの煩悩をなくさなくちゃいけないんです
煩悩をなくしちゃうと大丈夫なんです
例えば仏教でヴィパッサナー瞑想して悟っ
第一番目の預流果になったと
預流果になるためには五蓋は完璧に綺麗にならなきゃダメなんです
それで預流果の禅定が入ったと
入ってもそれからまた五蓋が出てくるんです
ですから一来果になるためには
また同じ戦いで瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
預流果になったんだから
別にもういくらかの煩悩は消えてますよ
二つぐらい それでもこれがまた出てくるんです
阿羅漢になったらもうそれっきり消える
本当に消える それから
抑える 抑えるっていう意味じゃないんです
これ 煩悩から五蓋が生まれるんです
ただ 怒りは煩悩でもあって
五蓋の一つもあるんです
カーマ・チャンダは煩悩でもあって
五蓋の一つでもあるんです
五蓋の働きで悟ったら煩悩は消える
煩悩消えちゃったら五蓋も当然ながらないんです
だから煩悩はいろいろ役目をやってるんですね
いろいろ役割を 禅定入っちゃうと煩悩が消えることじゃなくて
この五蓋としての役割はやらないということなんですね
まあ大体こんな話です今日は
で 色界はこの じゃああの
瞑想のことなんですけど
まあとにかく色界の心を作るためには瞑想しなくちゃいけない
それをサマーディ瞑想と言うんです
サマーディ瞑想するという場合は
やっぱりこの三次元のレベルを超えなくちゃいけない
で それに集中しなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから この何かを取って集中して瞑想すれば
徐々に徐々に心がそこらほう
そこら辺に面白くなってきて
欲の世界はどうでもいいことになってくるんですね
それで禅定の状態が生まれるという実践方法があるんです
例えば何か壁を見て瞑想すると
白い色を見て瞑想する
光を見て瞑想するとかね
あるいは慈悲の瞑想ばっかりやってるとかね
真剣に そういうふうにこの何かやってると
それしかやってないんだから
どんどんそこら辺に気持ちを行っていっちゃうんですね
そうすると他のことは別にもうどうでもいいことになってくる
そういうふうに五蓋が抑えちゃうんです
で 例えばこの壁を見て
この前説明しましたね
日本風なこの土 土色の壁とかね
そういうものを見て瞑想すると
なんかいろんな変なものを見始めるんです
普通だ 普段だったら何のこともない壁なんですけど
これ三十分ぐらいじっと見ていると
当たり前のことなんですけど
今まで見たことがない
いろんなことを見始めちゃうんです
そうするとそれ面白くなってくるんです
それでどんどん面白くなってきて
まあこんなもの食べるのはそんなどうでもいいと
こればっかりやっていて
それからこの次元を超えるためにちょっとした工夫してね
目を閉じてみる 閉じても見えるかないかと
閉じてでも壁見えるならば
あ 目に頼ることはいくらか心が頼らないんですね
で 目を閉じても見えるんだったら
ちょっとこの外 他のところに行って目を閉じて壁を見る
すると壁見える そこでまた瞑想し始める
そういうふうにやってきて
やがてこの どんどんその光見えてくるし
なぜならば目に見えるものは光だから
光見えてくると真理を
本物の物質見えてくる状態なんですね
で そこでさっと心のこの強引に活動している状態が消えちゃって
自然にドンと流れるような状態が生まれてくるんです
それ一体感として感じちゃうんですね
対象と自分が一つになったと
今まで自分がいて対象を見ている状態で
そこでいきなり対象と自分が一つに溶けちゃって
もうこの経験だけ知識だけ認識だけ流れていくような経験が生まれてくる
それが第一禅定なんです
で まあ五蓋だけ消えれば経験
経験できるんです そこで何回も何回も繰り返して繰り返して
それ同じことをやらなくちゃいけない
第一禅定に入ったんだからと言って威張っちゃったら意味がないんです
どうせご飯食べる時 ああ
これはすごい美味しいやと思って
そこに心がいっちゃったら
あれはもうもう二度と出てこない
それぐらいのものなんです
ですから ご飯をおいしく食べちゃってもいいんだけど
また何回も何回も何回もやってやって
自分の興味がご飯食べて音楽聴いて楽しい方ではなくて
この調世線の方に興味を大事にあるように